foreign
[Music]
season our main story tonight concerns
vacations a wonderful time to realize
that you're in love with someone or
realize that you are absolutely not and
be honest you knew in the TSA line
before the flight keep the streaming
passwords for as long as you can but do
give back his grandmother's ring
specifically we're going to talk about
time shares and some of you might be
thinking hold on are you going to tell
me that they are a scam because surely
everybody knows that and it is true that
the sketchiness of timeshare vacations
has been a punchline on TV for years
these aren't free vacations these
are time sharing deals they're total
scams these timeshare people they don't
stop until they sell you something they
they prey on the weak and gullible I eat
you perhaps you and your yellow friend
would like to set up a timeshare plan
don't do it Sandy
bam yeah suspicions about timeshare
programs are so ubiquitous they can get
lost in children's programming and look
obviously SpongeBob was never going to
say yes to a timeshare otherwise they'd
have had to change his theme song to
this
oh
who lives in a pineapple under the sea
except for one week a year when he's in
a studio in Key West
yeah it's still good but doesn't quite
have the same ring to it does it but
despite Decades of mockery on TV Time
Shares are a much bigger business than
you may think they're actually an 8.1
billion dollar industry with nearly 10
million households owning one or more
types of timeshare and they can be sold
by big hotel chains like Hyatt and
Marriott as well as companies like
Wyndham and Westgate Resorts but one of
the things that may have obscured their
continued growth is that they're not
always called time shares now in recent
years they've been rebranded as vacation
clubs or Vacation Ownership plans and
while traditionally you'd buy a
Timeshare that consisted of one week
every year at say a condo in Florida
nowadays companies offer floating weeks
that can theoretically be used anytime
throughout the year or time share points
where you buy points that you can redeem
in a number of Resort properties owned
by the same company but whatever you
call time shares the people selling them
maintain that they are not just
excellent value they are actively good
for you here is a vice president at
Westgate firing up his sales team in the
weirdest possible way why are we here
the save lives those who
SE occasions are most likely to have a
heart attack
you're just like a doctor nurse fireman
policeman
a lifeguard
they all save lives and you all do it
too you're right timeshare sales people
say
resources
valley during the initial outbreak of
the pandemic we New Yorkers would loudly
cheer for all the time share salespeople
as they came back from work we do that
at 6 p.m and then if we still had some
energy left we'd throw a few claps to
hospital workers at seven for whatever
they were doing
but the fact is timeshares don't save
lives in fact in many cases they can
them up because they are incredibly
easy to get into but as you will see
incredibly hard to get out of so tonight
let's talk about time shares let's start
with the first thing that you probably
already know about them that they tend
to be sold in person aggressively and
while you're already on vacation Often
by suckering people into agonizingly
long sales presentations with the
promise of a free gift there are so many
horror stories out there like the woman
whose parents was objected to a seven
hour sales pitch that ended with them
spending more than ten thousand dollars
on a timeshare or the person who signs
an agreement following a five-hour
presentation because quote I'm a
diabetic after five hours I just gave in
I needed something to eat and I do get
that listen to a timeshare presentation
is dead last on the list of things that
I want to do for five straight hours
right after watching avatar the way of
water telling children that their pet
hamster was eaten by their other pet
hamster and that neither one ever knew
the child in question existed and of
course hearing other people talk about
watching avatar the way of water
the problem is though once you are in
that room companies can go to extreme
lengths to get you to commit on the spot
just watch as that Westgate executive
encourages his staff to stop at nothing
to make a sale
our number one person in Orlando owned
several weeks of timeshare you know you
should own at least one week yourselves
and if you don't lie and say you do
don't let these people leave here
without buying something
I don't know what is more alarming there
that he knew a camera crew was filming
and still instructed his sales team to
lie or that he knew that and willingly
wore that shirt because what the is
that thing it looked like someone ate a
Persian rug and then threw up on it he
looks like the mascot for divorce
lying is actually a key strategy for
many timeshare sales people they will
lie about everything from the ease of
making reservations to the total cost of
the timeshare according to a lawsuit
against Wyndham salespeople even had an
acronym Taft which stood for tell them
any freaking thing and come on at this
point just say because it's one
thing to lie it's another to do that
while talking like a middle schooler
who's in the car with their mom but
still trying to sound hard
but the thing is lying is basically
allowed in this industry many timeshare
agreements contain a clause that
absolves the developer from
responsibility for anything sale reps
say it's often referred to by attorneys
as the salesman's license to lie clause
and look I get that sales reps
customers constantly it happens to me
every time a hobby pocket employee tells
me you look so cool but you wouldn't
expect them to be able to lie about
something as objective as how much a
thing will cost now the good news is
depending on where you made your
purchase you can have between three and
ten days to rescind your signature but
remember a lot of people sign up for
timeshares on vacation so that time time
May expire before they get home or have
a chance to have a lawyer look at the
contract and this would be less of an
issue if people generally loved their
time shares but a study found that 85
percent of timeshare owners regret their
purchase which is a rate of regret on
par with people who bought teacup pigs
only to realize that teacup pigs don't
really exist what do exist are baby pigs
that grow into a 90 pound piece of
lifestyle that can suffocate your cat
and at this point let's talk about why
people might regret buying a timeshare
and the first major reason
unsurprisingly is cost because The
Upfront cost for a one-week annual
timeshare vacation can average around
twenty four thousand dollars but that is
just the beginning because on top of
that come other expenses like
maintenance fees which typically go up
every year and at high value Resorts can
run from twenty five hundred to thirty
five hundred dollars per year and you
are on the hook for those costs whether
you use your timeshare or not which
actually brings us to another major
problem because if what you bought is
points or a floating week plan you still
need to book time at your Resort which
can be unexpectedly hard just listen to
this man explain his attempts to book a
vacation at the Westgate timeshare that
he bought in Branson Missouri six years
earlier the first year I call a month in
advance to say you're calling you're
giving us a very short notice so year
two they called six months in advance
you are calling too early year three
they called two months in advance but
we're told they called too late yeah you
can still go but uh we have to charge
you like any other person so far the
Nasir has spent more than fifteen
thousand dollars for a timeshare they've
never spent a single night in within a
serious complaint to Westgate they were
told they would have an easier time
using their timeshare if they upgraded
to a better plan for an additional
fifteen thousand dollars yeah that's not
great is it being asked to pay fifteen
thousand dollars is something that
you've only seen in pictures is not a
timeshare that's an expensive and
remarkably Niche only fans account
but westgate's response is pretty common
across the industry once you buy a
Timeshare the pitch is you really need
to upgrade to get the most or possibly
any thing out of your purchase and these
upgrades are a fundamental part of the
business model at one investment
conference Marriott stated that every
thirty thousand dollars spent on the
purchase of a new timeshare should
generate an extra 20 000 from upgrades
after just five years so it's hardly
surprising the company's frequently
pressure people to pay for upgrades
sometimes with the exact same aggressive
tactics that got them to buy the
timeshare in the first place customers
of Windham Resorts have said that
whenever they go on vacation they'd be
forced into so-called owner update
meetings where they were then pressured
to spend more like this woman the 76
year old Widow is deep in debt and when
more than 175 thousand dollars after she
claims she was repeatedly tricked and
harassed into buying time sharepoints
Ford's also claims in our lawsuit
Windham sales reps told her things to
convince her to buy more points that
ended up not being true if I would just
sign it then they could lower the
interest rates
is that in fact what happened no
no
she says Windham sales people also told
her the company would buy back any extra
points she didn't use and that too she
later found wasn't exactly as it had
been explained were you surprised to
discover that very surprised
not only surprised
he may need to bleep this out I was mad
as hell wow
wow she is pissed there I know Matt as
hell might not sound that extreme to us
delinquents on HBO but coming from a 76
year old woman in Tennessee that's
equivalent of a child screaming
through a bullhorn at an
elementary school it's that level of
intensity
so between fees and the constant
pressure to pay for upgrades you can see
how people might end up regretting their
purchase even those who initially
enjoyed their timeshare might end up
wanting to get rid of it either because
they're getting older and not wanting to
travel as much or they're just getting
tired of going to the same place but the
problem is whatever your reason for
wanting to leave a timeshare you will
soon realize it is very hard to do that
and that is because many agreements
contain a so-called perpetuity Clause
that means that the purchase as well as
all those regular maintenance fees are a
non-cancelable lifetime obligation which
is ridiculous a contract for a vacation
shouldn't be harder to get out of than
Scientology where's Shelley by
the way I'm sure she's fine but uh where
is Shelley now some developers claim to
have programs where they'll take a time
share back but there is a lot of fine
print there including the fact that
they're often only available at the
developers discretion and could involve
paying a significant fee which sometimes
can be equivalent to two years of
Maintenance fees and if the company
won't take it back good luck because it
can be hard if not impossible to sell a
timeshare in fact the resale site red
week shows a number of them being sold
for literally zero dollars and keep that
in mind anytime anyone says that a
timeshare is an investment Investments
are supposed to gain value a time share
is as sound and investment as opening a
d-lane Maxwell themed restaurant
dealies when you're here you're in
danger
and all this actually gets one step
worse thanks to something that's often
framed as a selling point for timeshares
it's a great feeling to know that our
grandchildren when we're not around yeah
and we'll be enjoying it it will be our
Legacy to them even as we
pass on it's something that we can
continue to give to our children it's a
gift that will keep on giving Beyond us
now that we have two children it's kind
of exciting that we know that our
credits will never go to waste it will
still be in our family through our voice
okay one of those boys seems happy about
that but the other one does seem pissed
and much more interested in the upside
down construction truck that he's
holding and he's honestly right because
if there's one thing to take away from
this episode it's that if you have a
choice between a time share and an
upside down truck take the truck every
time at least you technically own that
but given everything that you've seen so
far you won't be surprised to hear that
many people aren't super keen on
inheriting a timeshare and what you can
technically decline it that can be much
much harder to do than you might think
walking away does take work namely you
must file a disclaimer of Interest with
the court saying that you reject the
time share you only have nine months
after the death of your loved one to
file it and even then it's not that
simple you see when the first person in
line rejects the time share it goes to
the next in line and then the next and
the next every single person has to file
all of that paperwork it's true every
single person and timeshare paperwork
clearly isn't what grieving families
need it is pretty upsetting to think
that there might genuinely be a market
for sympathy cards that say I'm sorry
for your loss but also move fast if you
don't want to get stuck with the fees on
your dead mom's Hilton Head two bedroom
and all of this brings us what might be
the most surprising thing here
timeshares are so difficult to get rid
of a whole separate industry has now
cropped up known as the timeshare exit
industry you may have seen ads on TV for
the more upbeat segments on local
stations like these for a company called
timeshare termination team where they
can get a
strong endorsement
well timeshare termination team has a
hundred percent success rate joining us
trusted advisors Brian and Holly Wilbur
with the first steps you need to take to
legally get out of your timeshare I'll
be honest I know I said this before too
I didn't think this was possible but it
actually is now that sounds pretty great
doesn't it the basic pitch of exit
companies is for an upfront fee they'll
either resell your timeshare or get you
out of your contract and given how
critical they are of the timeshare
industry you might assume that they are
the good guys in this story
unfortunately they are very much not
which you probably already suspected
after that woman claimed a 100 success
right because that's one of those
phrases that's just an automatic red
flag like endorsed by Dr Oz or Forbes
cover model it just immediately raises
suspicions
also you should know well that sure
looks like the news crucially it and
although shows you just saw are
sponsored content programs we did a
story on them a couple of years ago and
it's where local stations will allow you
to buy your way into fake segments that
look like news but are in fact ads we
actually bought our way onto that exact
show on Denver 7 to sell a Nazi
blanket and if you missed that story go
back and watch the whole thing because
that was one hell of a sentence that's
missing about 21 minutes of context
anyway
as it turns out timeshare termination
team was even sketchier than our Third
Reich fleece because not not long
after that Denver 7's actual news team
had this story to report Debbie hired
the company in June 2019 in all she paid
more than fourteen thousand dollars
signed a contract a two-year contract
that ended this last June well under the
terms of the con if they don't resolve
my issue I can get a refund two years
came and went that's when she went
looking for answers so I came to came to
see them and it's empty the signs are
still up on this office in Greenwood
Village
but there's no employees the furniture
is gone wow first I'm not sure it was
totally necessary to force her to go
back and knock on the glass of a clearly
empty office but I'm very glad that they
did but second that is a 19th century
snake oil salesman level scam they just
disappeared one moment they were there
the next they were suddenly gone with no
warning like a ghost or a TV show on HBO
Max
everything's fine at this company
everything's fine
and unfortunately that is by no means a
one-off as one consumer Advocate puts it
I don't like generalization so I'll say
that 99 of them don't do what they say
they will or Worse are out and out scams
but you know what I do like
generalization so I'm happy to say
timeshare exit companies are total
a lot of follow to say basic
pattern that you just saw they'll charge
an upfront fee and then either stall
indefinitely Or fully disappear and they
are taking advantage of people on a
massive scale in Missouri one group of
companies stands accused of deceiving
consumers into paying more than 90
million dollars for exit services that
were not delivered and while that case
is still pending all of these other
companies have gone under in recent
years and I know that these exit
companies might seem immediately
suspicious to you now but they have
slick marketing and have also been
endorsed by some supposedly financially
Savvy people in fact Dave Ramsey the
popular personal finance Guru who to his
credit has been a vocal critic of
timeshares actually gave one exit
company a ringing endorsement time sure
exit team will get you out of their
timeshare
now you're going to pay them money to do
that that's what they do and they charge
you up front and they give your money
back guarantee if they don't get you out
but they'll get you out well that sounds
trustworthy doesn't it and after all why
wouldn't you take the word of a man
whose look and general Vibe answers the
question what if Billy Joel and Dr Phil
had a kid and it sucked but
but not long after that the Washington
State AG sued timeshare exit team
claiming among other things that the
majority of his customers either did not
receive their promised exit received one
that caused them unanticipated negative
Financial or other consequences or
received an exit that the customer could
have obtained for themselves the company
eventually shut down but only after it
was forced to pay 2.6 million dollars in
restitution and if you're thinking any
of that gave Dave Ramsey pause for
reflection you should know it did not
because after Inside Edition did a
segment covering timeshare exit teams
issues and questioning his endorsement
of them he pushed back like this I don't
know you could buy a story on Inside
Edition I didn't I didn't think you are
with that I know you were a tabloid but
I didn't know you were that low
or are you just so dumb that you didn't
understand you were on the wrong side of
this argument on the basis of the
consumer
so this is why timeshare is not on the
air anymore timeshare exit team but
guess who's still on the air
me
and I'm sitting
in a 300 million dollar paid for
building
neck deep in cash you jerks yeah
that is champion of the working people
Dave Ramsey bragging about being neck
deep in cash to his own viewers who got
caught up in a scam that he actively
promoted all while having his hands like
this
a pose used almost exclusively by
cartoon Super Villains plotting ways to
kill Batman
but the thing is there is no right side
to be on here timeshare companies and
timeshare exit companies are both
terrible one is a shitty business model
that's somehow technically legal and the
other is oftentimes an out and out scam
but neither is good and it's very
important not to lose sight of the fact
that beneath all of this are people who
can get victimized and in some cases
twice if you watch a lot of stories
about these companies it is
heartbreaking just how often the people
in them talk about how ashamed they feel
about falling for this nobody in my
family knows nobody makes you feel bad
when you think you've done something
that's stupid well we bought the
timeshare which took us to the cleaners
and it just made me feel stupid it
doesn't make me too good you know it's
like I I think I'm smarter than that
yeah I get that but to be clear the
shame here should not be on the people
who were duped it should be on the
industries that exploited them told them
any freaking thing they wanted to and
abused their understandable desire just
to take a break so what can we
do here well on the off chance that
anyone watching right now is considering
a time share don't do it if you know
someone considering it send them this
segment if you happen to inherit a
timeshare get rid of it as fast as
possible and if it's too late and you're
stuck with it you can try and give it
away for zero dollars online but the
truth is you'll only be someone
else over them unfortunately the best
option might actually be to call the
timeshare company and see if there is
any any chance that they will take it
back from you as for exit companies as
you have seen there's been sporadic
legal action against individual
companies but by and large it is a
whack-a-mole ecosystem when one goes
down another one tends to pop right up
so the truth is the best bet right now
seems to be to make sure that we all
warn each other about just how up
this whole industry is or I suppose we
could go another way with it and if you
can't beat them join them so joining me
now for a special sponsored segment that
she may or may not have paid three
thousand dollars for please welcome back
to the show my lovely wife Wanda Joe
Oliver
thank you
hello there Moana hello
no wonder I understand you have a new
timeshare product that you'd like to
share with us that's right I'm here to
introduce my new company timeshare exit
squared
yes the
ever timeshare exit company exit company
wow fascinating wonder what does
timeshare exit squared do exactly well
well let's say you're stuck in a
timeshare and you go to an exit company
to get you out of the contract but uh oh
that company just took all your money
and disappeared without doing a dang
thing well timeshare exit Square can
free you from your timeshare exit
company and get all your money back wow
that is amazing Wanda you are truly
saving lives just like doctors nurses
and firefighters
I am way better than all them
all those people are scum compared to me
I Spit on them
wow as you should my wander now tell me
how exactly does timeshare exit squared
work how does it work well
's here majon
they pay us a quick and easy upfront fee
of twenty thousand dollars
business months
your timeshare exit company will deposit
a full refund to your bank count wow
wonder is that guaranteed oh it's even
better than a guarantee it's a pinky
swear promise
I like it I like that that's what
squared has over 9.3 billion happy
customers and a 200 satisfaction rate a
200 percent you said that's right for
exit squared customer another random
person is all left satisfied wow
I wonder that is incredible I'll be
honest I didn't think this was possible
but it actually is
there is depending on your definition of
possible sure sure that's fair and if
you run into any problems or delays just
call our hotline at 1-800 Flowers oh
nice nice
yeah
to the timeshare exit squared offices
and you know what how would someone do
that my wonder will all you have to do
is drive up next to the timeshare exit
squared van and scream you're a 27 digit
case number
thing you need until we cross the border
into Nogales Mexico that sounds very
reasonable but people should act fast
shouldn't name a Wonder that's right but
John this particular company is only
going to exist for the next three days
I haven't I haven't well I could sell
you one week a year for just fifty
thousand dollars oh I like it and nobody
leaves here without buying something
she's right thank you so much my Wanda
that's our show thank you so much for
watching we're off next week we'll be
back after that good night thank you so
much